you
and we begin with Mark O'Meara Simek and
this is a first for our colloquium as a
professor of English at the Catholic
University of Valencia and a sworn
translator and interpreter of English
appointed by the Spanish Ministry of
Foreign Affairs and cooperation
he's a permanent researcher in the
Institute for Ethics in communication
and in organisations and he's been a
visiting scholar at the Centre for
business ethics in Bentley University
dr. O'Mara's research interests are
focused on the interaction of metaphor
framing and semantics in regard to how
they shape the ethical quality of
financial and other news reporting so
you get us started Michael what exactly
do you understand and what exactly do
you mean by ethically healthy
organisations is this just another way
of describing socially responsibility or
socially responsible companies or is it
really something distinctive and new and
different thank you for your question
bill I think that as a coming from the
area of English language studies it's
it's very interesting to understand the
importance of language in this process
of understanding what is organizational
health how can we understand the nature
or the natures of an organisation so
when we talk about csr and ethics I
think it's important to realize that
they're not synonymous terms sometimes
in economics discourse business ethics
discourse it's frequent to find them
talked about in the same terms as almost
as if talking about csr covers the same
territory as ethics and really they're
dealing with two different questions csr
response to social demands generally
speaking and ethics is concerned with
the moral judgement of specific actions
company actions individual actions so
ethically healthy organizations are
those that can achieve both through
we're going to be talking about today
which is a CSR that is moral and I think
that's what humanistic management does
and it's a way that we can produce
trusts as well
ethically healthy organizations are
based on virtue on operative habits how
we understand virtue that defend human
rights they defend human dignity and
contribute to the common good so
ethically healthy organizations promote
human flourishing and as a byproducts
are producing trusts what I'd like to do
today is talk about how we can come to a
basic understanding of this through what
we call organizational ethical quality
we've developed a scale that attempts to
map the different ways that ethical
quality can be understood so at the
bottom of the scale we could begin by
saying we there are companies that can
be considered ethically reprehensible
it's not difficult to find examples of
these companies these are companies that
unfortunately we read about in the
newspapers and we could say they don't
abide by ethical principles they carry
out unethical behaviors now next level
we can find companies that are ethically
compliant these are companies that are
aware and strive to comply with minerals
they respect human dignity their concern
is to avoid harm they're aware of
professional ethics and they do their
best to to follow the rules on the next
level we have ethically sensitized
companies these are companies that have
begin to consider at least at the
theoretical level are the importance of
ethics they strive to contribute to the
common good they're aware of moral good
they're aware of ethical criterion
values and what's interesting about this
is
ethically sensitized companies complete
the vocation in the calling and the
purpose of ethically compliant companies
and they do it with excellence being on
the next level up all right now let's
talk about the final level ethically
excellent companies these are companies
that go beyond complying minimal
requirements they go beyond
theoretically being aware of the value
of the moral code these are companies
that instill virtues operative practices
they go above and beyond so to speak the
call of duty so we have the word act we
repeat the word act because it's
important of virtue as a virtue when it
is can be perceived as an action and
it's a once again it's a habit so these
are companies that always act with with
moral virtues they act demonstrating
human excellence to improve people now
how do we improve people in an
organization well we go back to
instilling operative habits not only in
CEOs but in employees and we're
enriching the human quality of life that
in everyone who has contacts with the
company or organization now that brings
us to our concept of a moral corporate
social responsibility this is achieved
by having a look at how corporate social
responsibility has evolved thematically
and we have to talk about the first
stage which is an economic perspective
this is concerned with respecting
essentially making money for
shareholders and it it was the first
stage that we that we have now in terms
of social reaction this is this is
interesting because it's aware of more
of the civic responsibilities of a
company in terms of social action being
aware of what some of the currents are
it could be a compliance a focus as well
but it takes us to the next stage which
is social sensitive
again this is interesting because here
companies have realized that there are
currents within society that that can in
the in the long run be beneficial to
business it's a commercial opportunity
so we're improving the ethos of a
company in the long run finally we have
responsibility understood as social
action social action this is responding
to values in society incorporating these
values in every aspect of the
decision-making process alright this is
corporate social responsibility it's
devolves from more of a reactive
approach it's more of a proactive
approach and when you pair it with
organizational ethical quality which is
the vertical scale we have different
levels of moral corporate social
responsibility that can be that can be
and discussed so let's talk about some
examples I think it's important to
realize that a company can situate
itself in many different places along
such a scale the first example would be
a company that you could say doesn't
have ethical criteria in place they
don't abide by ethical criteria and they
have a more reactive approach when it
comes to corporate social responsibility
these would be examples once again of of
companies that that unfortunately make
headlines in both national and
international news and I think another
interesting example would be that of an
ethically virtuous company but with a
more reactive approach to corporate
social responsibility it's a curious
example because I'm I think of a company
that produces very good shoes while
they're providing value to society
they're also instilling virtue in their
workers and in everyone with whom the
company comes in contact now maybe they
don't participate in financing NGOs
maybe they don't have as many programs
that would be
socially more inlined with some of the
latest trends in csr however they're
enriching the lives of those with whom
the company comes into contact now let's
talk about an example of a company that
would have an absence of ethics but a
very inclusive a very dynamic csr
structure I think about news media
companies that have eliminated their
print editions to reduce the carbon
footprint yet at the same time engage in
inaccurate reporting on financial events
through linguistic and semantic and
cognitive tools such as metaphor such as
conceptual metaphor this is important
because if people have a right to be
informed financial news reporting
fulfills that need and it informs
real-life decisions so this has the
potential of promoting trusts promoting
stability or achieving the opposite now
finally there are companies that are
both ethically virtuous and have very
inclusive very proactive approaches to
corporate social responsibility these
are companies that that do both these
are companies that achieve the highest
levels of ethical virtuousness companies
like Patagonia these in the long run not
only defend human rights defend human
dignity and contributes to the common
good but they do it with with excellence
I think they realize in the long run
that the human person is an intrinsic
good and an end in itself not not a
means to achieve another and so I think
Michael will talk a little bit more
about this in his presentation so thank
you very much
you